Lear non SP pour rien alorsen ça Mme
pour
faire c'estant de et le retard de
croissance là il pas seulement de vente
il pense plutôt les de de
tête mais que pourou la porte mais ça
va bonjour bonjour mademoiselle Martin
je suis la sage femme entrez je vous en
prie bonjourur vous attendez avec
impatience merci
installez-vous ch oui tu es meilleur à
l'intérieur bon ben je vais vous poser
quelques questions pour voir un petit
peu pourquoi ce retard de croissant chez
ce bébé vous avez quel âge madame elle a
30 ans madame 30 ans c'est bien ça oui
30 ans c'est ce que j'ai dit oui vous
avez des enfants oui on a un petit
garçon il s'appelle romain il a 4 ans
mais là il est pas là il est à
l'école d'accord un petit garçon de 4
ans donc oui c'est bien ça vous
travaillez madame oui elle travaillait
elle était infirmière mais elle a arrêté
pour s'occuper du petit on va pas
laisser n'importe qui s'occuper de nos
enfants de nos jours c'estt qu'on a un
problème là oui le bébé a un petit
retard de croissance est-ce que il y a
des problèmes de santé dans votre
famille ah sa famille mon Dieu
heureusement que j'étais là je lui
interdit de fréquenter sa famille et
heureusement justement que j'étais là
parce que maintenant elle se sent mieux
donc ça va madame c'est mieux parce que
sa famille complètement dingue d'accord
et vous madame vous avez des problèmes
de santé
elle est complètement folle c'est pour
ça que Jul interit de sortir je sais ce
qu'elle est capable de
faire on va faire le point par rapport à
votre alimentation comment ça se passe
alimentation madame elle est
complètement anorexique
anorexique vous êtes préoccupé en ce
moment préoccupé pas qu' se plaindre je
vois pas d'autres préoccupations
hein bon apparemment c'est un petit peu
tendu euh je va tendu parce qu'on est un
peu tendu nous non non non en fait je
voulais vous proposer quelques exercices
de relaxation ça ça peut faire du bien
pour le bébé également donc ok ben je
vous laisse seul euh vous désirez
peut-être un café madame volontiers
merci ok ben je prépare ça de suite je
reviens et toi je te propose rien parce
que tu vois tout
dégueuler ça va madame bien merci il me
semble que vous êtes victime de violence
conjugale quoi mais il m'a jamais frappé
hein